Hello everybody. Yes, it's my pleasure to be
chairing this session on the necrotic tumor microenvironment as an
instigator of metastatic aggression and immuno evasion.
My name is Kevin Chung. I'm an associate professor at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer
Center in Seattle, and in today's session, we're
really going to be talking about an area that I think is of emerging interest but
remains really poorly understood.
It's an area of necrosis and its contributions
to metastatic progression and
immuno evasion. So, these are my disclosures.
And so to set the stage, I think in the
medical field every
efficient scientist, every physician goes through training,
and they read this textbook, Robbins and Kumar, "Pathologic Basics of
Disease." And one of the first things they learn is about
necrosis, which is this idea that a
normal cell subject to stress
adapts, but when it fails to adapt, it undergoes cell injury.
And when that injury is irreversible,
one of the outcomes is necrosis.
So really this is the framework where we think about necrosis is
fundamentally a pathologic process and a failure of normal
cells to adapt.
Now in cancer,
necrosis is a pathologic feature of aggressive tumors.
We know very well that you can find necrotic areas on
scans, on MRIs, as shown here with glioblastoma,
and these are associated with clinically worse prognoses.
You can find it in different types of subtypes of breast cancer and other types of
cancers. Here, like shown here, basal-like triple-negative.
And these regions, these perinecrotic zones,
have emerged as a significant interest.
Poor prognosis, virtually all tumor types associated with fast-growing
tumors. And really, I think one of the important features is clinically we
tend to avoid these areas for molecular studies because the
thought process is that the tissue is dead and we should be looking for
genetics, looking for mutations, looking for protein changes
somewhere else.
Now, on a cellular level,
I believe necrosis is very well understood, in terms of the
ultrastructural biochemical changes
really leading to mitochondrial and membrane failure.
So on an individual cell level, we can say that's undergoing necrosis or
not. Pathologists can say that's undergoing necrosis or
not. But I would say for the purposes of today's talk,
at the tissue system level, tumor necrosis is far less understood.
It really involves a variety of processes of interest to the audience here today,
in terms of both the insults, ischemia, thrombosis, hypoxia that
drive it, the immune mediators, neutrophils,
macrophages, and also the different types of stressors like
therptosis and other forms of cell death that may participate.
We're not going to cover all of these topics in such a
symposium today, but there's a lot of
interest in the field to look at this more closely.
In addition, necrosis is not simply the endpoint of cell death, but
also spawns a variety of processes, including increased
metastatic dissemination of CTCs, circulating tumor cells, and really nice work
showing that this is an eco-evolutionary system that leads to clonal evolution
and selection for metastatic clones.
There's also been work showing that the stem and tissue sort of
regenerative programs are activated in these regions, and there are clear
consequences for both drug delivery, perfusion, and immune
evasion.
Now, in today's symposium, we're going to really have sort of all-star
presentations from
different perspectives.
First, Jose Drover from the Francis Crick will be presenting on
his work looking at the role of cancer-induced host
remodeling and neutrophil plasticity.
This will be followed by work by Dr.
Carlos Camona Fontaine at NYU looking at the role of tumor
immune interactions at the verge of these necrotic cores and how we can study it,
which is really a really major gap in this area.
And finally,
I will be giving a talk on the role of the necrotic niche as a sculptor of the
dissemination and metastatic process.
So without further ado, I'm going to have Jose come up to the podium.
Thank you.
Okay.
Let me stop this,
and
I need to stop the presentation. There you go.
Okay. Well, thank you very much for the introduction, and thank you all for being
here. I have no financial
relationship to disclose. So I thought I'd first start by introducing my lab a
little bit because I recently moved to the UK to the Francis Crick
Institute
a little over a year ago, where my lab is called the Cancer Macroenvironment Lab.
And this is because we're very interested in understanding how cancer affects whole
body physiology because growing tumors, as you know, affect a whole array of
different physiological systems.
And what usually happens is that the changes that tumors inflict to those systems
usually loop back and fuel tumor growth.
Now of all these different systems in the lab, we're particularly interested in how
cancer affects the cardiovascular system, and I will show you a little bit about
that at the end of my talk today. But also the hematopoietic and the
immune system. Above all immune cells, we are particularly fond of neutrophils,
which are these fellas here.
And we're very interested also in their ability to form neutrophil extracellular
traps, which are these structures that they form by basically dismantling their
nuclear membrane and mixing the chromatin with the cytotoxic
contents of their granules.
And then they release this meter long mesh of DNA and
cytotoxic compounds to the external world as you see here.
And these are very cytotoxic and also very prothrombotic structures, which is going
to be important for my talk later.Now, I'm going to start
by telling you a bit about a project that I did when I was still a postdoc in the
Eggebrecht lab, first at Cold Spring Harbor and then at Johns Hopkins.
We were trying to understand a little bit better tumor necrosis, which has been
already alluded, is an often-overlooked phenomenon that happens in most solid
tumors,
but is one phenomenon that is associated with bad prognosis for patients
as was said already. This is one example in colorectal cancer
patients, where you see that patients with a lot of necrosis fare much worse as
patients with no necrosis in their tumors.
And we actually recapitulated this in a cohort of breast cancer patients, where you
again see here that these patients have a lot of necrosis in their tumors fare much
worse in terms of recurrence-free survival.
Same thing was true for overall survival.
And importantly, patients with necrotic tumors have a lot more metastasis here
measured as axillary adenopathy.
And this was true all across the board of breast cancer subtypes.
But one thing that we were trying to understand is what drives tumor necrosis,
because we don't know what drives tumor necrosis beyond this rather intuitive idea
that tumors grow very quickly, and then at some point, the innermost core central
regions of the tumor become hypoxic and then necrotic.
And I'll try to argue that this is not necessarily always the case.
Now, instead, what we find is that neutrophils can aggregate
within the vessels of the tumor, microvasculature,
and they can form nets within the vessels of the tumor.
Now, these nets are highly prothrombotic structures, so what they're doing in the
end by aggregating within the vasculature is blocking the blood flow in that
particular vascular branch, and that leads to downstream hypoxia and then later
on to necrosis. And this is something that you can see here.
And these are 41
tumors,
and we injected a vascular dye to these mice here in red.
So to show vessels which are perfused, the vessels not perfused in green, and the
neutrophils in cyan.
And we very often find vessels like this one, as you can see, is perfused, and then
at some point, perfusion stops. And where perfusion stops, we
invariably find one of these big intraluminal neutrophil
aggregates.
So there's perfusion, then we have the neutrophil aggregate, and from that point
downstream, there is no perfusion anymore.
Now, why are neutrophils doing this?
Well, to cut a long story short, what we found basically is that the
tumor is remotely communicating with the hematopoietic compartment in the bone
marrow
and is inducing a myeloid skew of hematopoiesis.
It's inducing the increased production of the granulocyte/monocyte progenitors and
a systemic increase in neutrophils all over the place.
But it's also inducing the appearance of a new population of neutrophils, which
have low levels of L6C, these L6Clow neutrophils.
And these neutrophils have two very interesting characteristics, in my opinion.
The first one is that these L6Clow neutrophils don't
extravasate towards inflammatory stimuli.
This is what you can see here in a classical peritonitis model, where we can find
these L6Clow neutrophils in blood.
They're completely absent in the peritoneal lavage, and we confirmed this using
intravital microscopy as well. So that's why we call these neutrophils, these
L6Clow neutrophils, we call them vascular restricted neutrophils because they are
restricted to the vascular space, and they cannot leave.
The other thing these neutrophils do very differently is that they form a lot more
NETs than the normal neutrophils from the same host.
And actually NETs, we found out are actually very important
for this process of necrosis, because when you have tumors in mice that are
genetically unable to form necrosis,
then necrosis in these tumors is greatly reduced. Sorry.
And this is showing what I think it's a very
interesting thing, which is that tumor necrosis is not necessarily
a passive phenomenon. It can actually be an active phenomenon driven by
neutrophils, and in particular by neutrophils forming NETs in the luminal
compartment of the vasculature of those tumors.
And that is important because, as was alluded already, tumor necrosis is
associated with bad prognosis across the board of cancer types.
Now, if you think that tumor necrosis is a passive phenomenon, that there's
basically not much you can do about it.
But now that we know that it's an active phenomenon, at least in some cases driven
by the neutrophils, it means that we can target that phenomenon, and we can
reduce tumor necrosis. And when we do that,
when we target the NETs, we reduce tumor necrosis, but we also
reduce metastasis. We reduce metastatic spread.
Now, we confirmed this using various other means.
So, for instance, here you see if your mice
are neutropenic, if you don't have neutrophils, this is in the Lewis lung model,
then your tumors are not too necrotic.
If you treat mice with disulfiram, this is the G2 untapped genetic spontaneous
model.
And we published a couple of years ago that disulfiram is a drug that is able to
block NETs very efficiently. Then you can also reduce tumor necrosis.
Same thing is true if you block with TI05 and neutrophil platelet interactions,
which are very important for the initiation of NETs within the luminal compartment.
You can also reduce tumor necrosis in this case.
And if you treat your mice with DNase 1, which is able to degrade the NETs once
they've been formed,
that also reduces tumor necrosis.
And in all of these cases where we looked at lung metastatic spread, we saw a
decrease in lung metastasis.
Now, why is that?
Again, I'm cutting a long story short, but what we found basically is that when you
have necrosis, well, you're not going to have
viable cancer cells in that area. But what you also generate is this
perinecrotic region
around the necrotic area where we find that cancer cells are changing and
gaining pro-metastatic features. So here's one example.
You can see here how vimentin is nicely expressed around these
perinecrotic regions. And more generally, when we have a look at the terms which
are upregulated in perinecrotic regions compared to the non-necrotic regions of
these tumors,
we find many terms related to hypoxia, EMT, and migration.
Many TGF-beta pathways, epithelial to mesenchymal transition pathways,
and epithelial cell migration pathways.
So it seems like specifically in these perinecrotic regions of the tumor, cancer
cells are gaining these pro-metastatic traits.
And we show in the paper that TGF-beta is actually critical for these processes,
necrosis enhanced metastatic spreadSo I'm going to
stop here with this story because it's already published and you can have
a look there. But in general terms, what we found was that the tumor is
communicating remotely with the bone marrow, changing bone marrow dynamics,
increasing the production of neutrophils, and making
a new population of neutrophils that was not described before appear, these LY6C
low neutrophils, which are restricted to the vasculature and can
aggregate within the luminal space, block the blood flow, and cause downstream
regions of tumor to become hypoxic first and then necrotic,
and that in turn generate this perinecrotic area around it where through
TGF-beta we have this phenotype that increases metastatic spread.
Now, I'm going to switch now to show you some of the projects which
are ongoing in the lab at the moment.
Bear in mind, my lab is still very young. I've been there for a little over a year.
But I want to show you a little bit about what we're doing in terms of the cancer
cardiovascular disease interplay, because it correlates, we believe, with these
neutrophils that we find are causing necrosis. Now, why are we interested in this?
Well, we're interested because
cancer patients have a lot more cardiovascular disease than the general population,
and here are some examples. Myocardial infarction, much higher mortality
in cancer patients. Same thing for an incidence of stroke, and of course,
thrombosis, which is one of the main problems that we have clinically
when treating these patients.
Now, we're looking into this in three different angles.
The first one is trying to understand how cancer affects the heart directly,
how it affects thrombosis, and how it affects atherosclerosis.
But I'm going to be talking today mostly about
how cancer affects the heart.
So research on
this area is focusing nowadays mostly on how
cancer treatments affect the cardiovascular health and the heart in
particular, because many cancer treatments are cardiotoxic directly.
But when you look at the clinical literature, you see that
treatment-naive patients are also at much higher risk of cardiovascular disease.
So what we believe is that there must be something beyond cancer treatment that is
affecting cardiovascular health.
And in that sense, we believe that these LY6C low vascular restricted neutrophils
that we found in our cancer models, which are restricted to the vasculature and
highly reactive within the vessels, and which also interact more with platelets
and fibrin, these neutrophils are in a good position to be able to
explain the high burden of cardiovascular disease in these cancer patients.
Why is that? Well, because as I showed you at the beginning, they can aggregate
within the vessels of the tumor, and they can block the blood flow there, but
there's nothing in principle that will stop them from doing that
outside of the tumor, potentially in the coronary arteries.
And this is actually what we see. This is in the 4T1 model, and this is a heart,
and this is a coronary artery on the heart.
And what we're seeing is that neutrophils can also aggregate within the
vasculature of the heart in this particular case,
and they can form aggregates, and there's also fibrin in these regions and so
on. Here's another example. This is a big aggregate of neutrophils in the
heart with some fibrin. What I would like to point your attention to in this image
is this area here, where you see there's a lot of these neutrophils crawling
around the vessels of the heart, and there's a reduction in the profusion in that
particular area.
Now,
the other interesting observation that we have is that neutrophils can form nets in
the hearts of these mice, and this is interesting because we haven't done
anything to the hearts of these mice.
So these mice have a tumor, and that's it, and then we see these neutrophils
forming nets in the heart of these mice.
And we know that nets are important drivers of damage in the heart, and
this is one example here.
In acute myocardial infarction, they are drivers of damage because if you block
them with chloramine, or if you degrade the nets with DNase,
we can reduce by roughly one-third the amount of
dead myocardium. So nets are drivers of acute myocardial infarction.
So what's going on in our tumor models?
So
this is in the 4T1 model. We implant the tumor, and then we were started to look at
the heart in these mice. And what we see is that as the
tumor progressed, the number of these vascular restricted neutrophils, which start
crawling around the vasculature of the heart, increases, and that
coincides with an increase on heart fibrosis.
And again, this is very interesting for us because, again, we haven't done anything
to these hearts. These mice have a tumor, and the heart is becoming fibrotic
as a result.
We find the same in another model. This is the Lewis Lung model.
At endpoint, we also have increased cardiac fibrosis in this model.
Now,
the next thing we ask is whether these changes that we're seeing in fibrosis are
somehow affecting the function of these hearts.
So we did MRI imaging to assess the functional status of the hearts in these mice.
And what we see is basically this. So as tumors progress,
the end systolic volume is increasing, so the leftover
blood after systole is increasing, which means that the
heart isn't able to pump all of the blood
it contains. And that's why the ejection fraction is coming down.
So the contractile performance of the heart is declining,
but the heart is at the moment compensating by increasing the volume at
end-diastolic. So the heart is compensated by getting more
blood in before it contracts.
And therefore, the cardiac output is for now maintained in these mice.
But this comes with a cost, and the left ventricular mass is actually increasing.
So there's a structural remodeling, and there are functional changes in the
heart of these mice. So heart function is indeed affected by growing tumors
independently of treatment.
So what we're seeing is consistent with human heart failure progression.
We're seeing this fibrosis and a progressive left ventricular remodeling with
worsening systolic emptying, and also, I didn't show you, but there's slower
filling and ejection dynamics in these hearts.
Now, the forward output, the cardiac output of the heart is still maintained
because the heart is compensating.
This is called Frank-Starling preload compensation, and it's something that
typically happens in humans as well, but it's a compensation that will not last
forever. It will eventually decompensate.So this is what we know
so far. We know that
in cancer, we have neutrophils forming NETs in the heart, we have neutrophils
aggregating in the vasculature of the heart, and we have
changes in the heart fibrosis and function.
Now, we still don't know whether this is driven by neutrophils or NETs.
So hopefully, I'll be able to tell you more about this in the future.
And whether cardiovascular events in cancer patients correlate with the presence of
NETs also, and most importantly, whether we can
prevent this by pharmacologically blocking NETs
upon cancer diagnosis.
And then I'm going to switch to another project that I would like to tell you a bit
about. It has to do with this vascular-restricted neutrophil,
this Ly6C low neutrophil. So what are they doing? Where do they come from?
And we're finding that these neutrophils may represent an oncofetal reversion of
neutrophil programs in cancer.
So this started from a completely different project, where we were looking at
neutrophils in the embryos, because neutrophils are present in developing embryos
around mid-gestation. You can see them here. There's lots of them.
They are enlarged so that you can see them, lots of them in the liver, and
there's also aggregates of these neutrophils here and there all over the body.
Now, we were looking into this because neutrophils show remarkable plasticity
during embryonic development, and they change a lot across embryonic time,
both at the level of the hematopoietic stem and progenitor cells and also of the
mature neutrophils. The mature neutrophils, you have them here.
Around mid-gestation, there's a population of neutrophils that comes up here
that we are studying, and we're very interested in understanding what they are
doing. But the interesting thing comes that when we were looking at the
neutrophils of these embryos, what we found was that these
Ly6C low neutrophils that we find in the context of cancer
appear naturally during embryonic development.
So they are there around mid-gestation, and then upon birth, they
disappear completely. And we don't see them again.
So these vascular-restricted neutrophils, they apparently appear naturally during
embryonic development. Then we lose them after birth, and they don't appear again
unless you have a tumor where this population comes out again.
This is just to show you that these are really neutrophils because we sorted them.
Now, the next question is: how similar are these embryonic Ly6C low
neutrophils to the ones that we find in cancer?
Well,
what we did here was to have a look at the genes which are upregulated or
downregulated in these Ly6C low neutrophils that we find in cancer and
compare them with the Ly6C low neutrophils that we find during development.
And as you can see here, most of the genes which are upregulated are still
upregulated. Most of the genes which are downregulated are still downregulated.
So there's a remarkable similarity between these neutrophils that we find in the
embryo and the neutrophils that we find in cancer.
Actually, there's over 70% concordance in the genes that are going up or
down in both cases.
So we are thinking is that these cancer-elicited Ly6C low neutrophils represent
a tumor-induced reversion of hematopoiesis to a
mid-gestational program that includes the production of these
vascular-restricted neutrophils.
So now we're very interested in understanding what are the embryonic features of
these neutrophils because we believe that that is going to help us understand what
are they doing in the context of cancer.
And they have many different things that they do differently, many related to
angiogenesis, lots of developmental pathways, neural pathways,
cartilage, bone development, matrix organization.
And I'll just show you a couple of examples here.
So
these Ly6C low neutrophils, when it comes to angiogenesis, they show
a shift from a more classical inflammatory neutrophil angiogenesis
program with a classical ECM degrading, ECM opening, and the inflammatory
angiogenetic neutrophil effector phenotype.
And they move to a vascular patterning, endothelial
guidance, junction organization, remodeling program.
So these Ly6C low neutrophils in the context of the embryo and in cancer
can potentially influence vascular organization.
This is something that we're looking now in the context of cancer to see whether
these neutrophils are doing something regarding vascular patterning there.
The other thing I would like to point out here is whether when you look at the
genes related to the interaction of these neutrophils to the
vascular walls, we also see an interesting shift
between a more classical inflammatory interaction program
driven by selectins and in beta-2 integrins to a
program that has more to do with a stable wall interaction, beta-1
integrin-dependent adhesion,
including fibronectin receptors and these other integrin, which is
also binding laminin as well as fibronectin.
So these
Ly6C low neutrophils in the embryo as well as in cancer, they're gaining genes
associated with this beta-1 substrate engagement and
more stable interaction.
So what we're thinking is that these Ly6C low neutrophils in development are
an endothelial guidance and patterning population that is programmed to
form stable interactions at the vessel wall.
Now in cancer, they appear again.
And what happens is that we believe is that they're suddenly exposed to
pro-inflammatory stimuli, which would otherwise be completely
absent in the embryo, which is in a sterile environment.
So they are unable to extravasate, but they remain able to form NETs, and they
respond by forming these NETs that then drive thromboinflammatory
occlusion, tumor necrosis
in the end.
So we're currently exploring how the developmental programs of these
vascular-restricted neutrophils can shape tumor progression.
And one of the genes that I'll point out here that we find downregulated,
both in the embryonic Ly6C low neutrophils as well as in the cancer Ly6C low
neutrophils, is CD177.
And of interest to this audience may be to attend Sepideh Golami's talk on
Tuesday because she's going to be talking about this molecule in particular and how
NET inhibition relates to necrosis reduction in colorectal cancer and
colorectal cancer metastasis.
And with that,
these are the people in the lab. Most of the work that I've shown you today was
done by Saira, Afshan, or Nathan.
And these are my collaborators, funding sources, and I'll thank you for
your attention. Thank
you.Oh,
got you. Sure.
Hi. You're proposing that these
neutrophils occur from altered hematopoiesis.
Do you think that's at all related to emergency myelopoiesis
and sort of related,
do you think you can mimic the Ly6C low
neutrophils with a common infection or something like that?
So we think that emergency myelopoiesis is going to be involved, but
we think that is not sufficient. So common
infection, for instance, we look for them in sepsis and we cannot find them.
So it's not an easy population to find.
Now,
I would say that when you look at the progenitors in these
tumor-bearing mice,
there's an upregulation of CPP beta, which is a known driver of
emergency myelopoiesis. So we believe that emergency myelopoiesis may be
necessary but not sufficient to make these neutrophils appear.
Hi, a very nice talk. You show a very nice correlation
between an increase in fibrosis and an increase in the
recruitment of neutrophils. So,
I wonder if in your model you also have a mechanistic understanding of if
there is a mechanistic connection between these two processes, and in particular,
if the release of collagen fragments that arises during
fibrosis can also attract or help this recruitment of neutrophils.
Yeah, so that's a really good question.
The short answer is we don't know. So we just started working on this.
But we're working on what the mechanism is at the moment.
So hopefully next time I'll be able to... Yeah.
So thank you very much for the talk. Fantastic pictures.
I had a question about sort of the size of the vessels that these
microemboli could target. Are we solely looking at capillary beds, or are they
able to target much bigger? And if so, do we have a
sense of what that size limit is and if they pass into the venous system?
Yeah. So,
we did look at the size of these obstructions.
We don't see them only in very small capillaries.
We see them in vessels up to 100 microns in diameter.
So,
as far as we can tell, it can happen in all sorts of different
ranges of vessels. The point is that once
the neutrophil and the platelet, which are important for this process, start
interacting and inducing this net formation, there's a feed-forward loop
that I think will basically cover at least up to 100 micrometer
diameters.
And to clarify, this is primarily in the outgoing
arterial system. Do we see these in venous structures?
We did not look
at veins versus arteries, actually. That's a good point. We'll have a look.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Mark Malkin, Neuro-Oncology, Cleveland Clinic.
So in the brain tumor space, we deal with two types of necrosis.
We deal with the pseudopalisading necrosis around a
glioblastoma, and we also deal with radiation necrosis,
particularly in the metastatic population that have received
radiosurgery.
Mm-hmm.
So do these neutrophils also
participate in the necrosis?
Because you know how we treat radiation necrosis, we treat it with bevacizumab,
which is prothrombotic.
Yeah.
So we don't know. We never looked at glioblastoma.
I know that there's work that has shown that neutrophils are important in
glioblastoma necrosis, but we have never looked, so I don't really know.
I can't tell you at the moment, but it's a good point. Yeah.
So, you know the expression of a LIR-1 inhibitory receptor
in these intravascular neutrophils?
Of what receptor, sorry?
LIR-1 inhibitory receptor on these neutrophils,
and whether since these receptors sense the collagen and you
correlate that with fibrosis. So I would suppose if they have the
receptor to be blocked to the
necrosis rather than favor it.
Yeah.
I don't know. We haven't looked at that particular receptor, but that's a good
point. We'll have a look. Thank you.
So there's a reflex to think that the cells that are not
irrigated anymore obviously have to die.
But is that death a passive or an active death?
And have you looked and are there any factors made throughout that
death process?
Are there factors made-
Factors that would then stimulate the metastasis.
Right.
So short answer is we don't know. So we know that there is necrosis.
So the way that I think about it is that you will have
these
hypoxia, these loss of oxygen, and eventually cells will start to become necrotic.
Now, most likely there's going to be a mixture of different cell death
modalities happening there.
How do you know that?
I don't know. That's-
Okay. I
think you need to rigorously test that with inhibitors-
We could
... of different cell death. Because what I think what could happen is that then
you block the production of some of those factors that drive metastasis.
Yeah. That's a good point. Thank you.
Excellent discussion. Now it's time for our second speaker,
Dr. Fogg.
All right.
So, thank you Kevin for the invitation, putting together this great
symposium, and all of you for coming.
So we've heard already a great talk about
part of the mechanisms that generate
these necrotic
regions in the tumor. Really interesting to see that it's not just a
passive effect, but you can have cells that promote that.
The part that we are interested in as a lab is once you
have those regions formed, how that affects
cell behaviors. And part of it is just not enough
vasculature or enough functional vasculature for a
tumor cell. So you have here, peritumoral
tissue. There's a lot of vasculature per cell.
As you move into the tumor, there is just simply not enough vasculature or
maybe some of this vasculature are clogged by these neutrophils, as we just
heard.
But
that means that you don't only get a super
well profused region in the tumor and then a binary change towards an
ischemic region. You actually have a whole gradient of change.
And as a lab, what we're interested is how those different regions, the different
levels of nutrients and metabolites affect cell
behavior,
and partly how that affects different tumor functions, but also how it
affects the interactions with immune system.
And the interesting thing is, once you consider the vasculature, these changes in
metabolites are actually quite predictable.
So here's just showing for hypoxia.
And what you can see is that you have a pretty consistent, roughly
100-micron gradient from a vasculature to
highly hypoxic and ischemic tissues.
So
when studying this problem,
we started looking at
macrophages. This was ages ago. I'm sure you read the paper, so I'll just
do a quick recap only.
And this was right before single-cellseq
became
widely available. So
we're super proud that we found two populations of tumor-associated
macrophages. Now, I think there are 17.
But basically, what we found, we found this particular population of
arginase-1 expressing macrophages.
In humans, it tends to be neutrophils.
But across species, you have this population
of ischemic myeloid cells always expressing arginase-1, and they
are associated with this sort of peri-necrotic region.
And we thought that what was interesting, and we found how those
macrophages were adopting that phenotype.
But
what I wanted to talk today is to discuss a little bit what are the
mechanism and what is the arginase-1 doing in those
macrophages. And they are interesting because they are immunosuppressive.
They tend to prevent the function of
cytotoxic T cells. And we thought that this sort of marker of
macrophages or this ischemic myeloid cells was particularly interesting
because the ischemic
stimuli that were triggering these macrophages is obviously metabolic, but the
response, this arginase-1 is not just a marker, it's actually a metabolic enzyme,
typically from the liver. So we thought that there could be some
sort of metabolic crosstalk there that could be interesting.
But before I get into the function of these cells, I wanted to introduce you a
little bit of the sort of devices that we've been doing.
So one of the ways we study this problem, how different gradients and the
access to nutrient affect cells, is through
this system.
I guess now they are called new approach methodologies.
That's the new NIH requirement. But
basically, it's super simple. You just grow cells in a tiny volume
here, and the cells are sandwiched between two coverslip.
Now, the trick is that the top coverslip is offset, so it leaves a little
opening. So if you are a cell here, you will be happy,
access to oxygen and to all the resources.
But as you go deeper into this region, you get progressively more ischemic
because the cells in front of you are consuming the nutrients.
So this is just to show that it works.
These are cells that are engineered to express GFP under the
Kif1
responsive element. And you can see this population switching to this
GFP-positive region. People get surprised about the binary
switch of GFP, but that's just the way Kif1 alpha works, so
degraded or not.
So since we were talking about... So I usually show the photo
I took here, but since we're talking about necrosis, I just
show a little bit. As you go deeper into the gradient, you start seeing
cells actually dying over there. And if you keep it for several days,
you'll have a true necrotic core.
We also have now a version that is great for 3D
analysis. And here, I think we haven't really
studied this much, but
we thought it's really interesting.
In ischemic regions, the tumor seems to be actually grabbing macrophages into
the tumor. So we don't know if this is what you would have in vivo,
but it's basically a system. It's incredibly easy
to make, and I think it can allow you to visualize a lot of
these processes. So actually, we've
looked with some collaborators at many different factors.
So we can see transitions toward a more mesenchymal
phenotype in these more ischemic cells.
We've seen changes in cell proliferation, and basically, many things
happen.
But...
That was my talk. No.
Maybe we can reset it.
Okay.
So my name is Carlos Carmona. I'm going to present.
Yeah. So basically,
now you got how the system works. So,
what I'm going to present now is going back to these arginase-1
macrophages, and what I hopefully will be able to show you,
it's a version of this systemWhere
it's not used for microscopy, but what we
actually do-- Oh, there we go.
Is that we extract cells from
different...
Okay.
Well, I guess the patent office at NYU is going to be really happy because they
hate every time I present this. They're like, "Can you file us
about the..."
Yeah. But basically, it's a new system.
So what we do is we grow cells in a little tray,
and once the cells are adhered into this tray, we can sort of
slide the tray into one of these chambers.
Now, the tray is pre-cut, so after the experiment, you remove
the tray, split it into pieces, and you can analyze these different
regions with any kind of omics that you want.
Right? So for us, it was interesting because we knew that we have
these macrophages that express arginase 1.
They only appear in these ischemic regions, but we really wanted to do is to
know what metabolic rewiring was happening in those macrophages,
and potentially how...
Now we can?
Ah, there we go. Okay. So
this is a co-culture of cells with macrophages.
Again, this arginase 1 you see here.
All the macrophages in green, they almost never express arginase 1,
but in this ischemic region, they basically all switch to this phenotype.
And you can have that even if you have macrophages alone.
So this is going to be important. If you have enough macrophages, they just
spontaneously start expressing arginase 1 only in these ischemic regions.
So what's the role of these
macrophages, and how is the arginase 1 affecting
potentially tumor progression?
So this is the system I was telling you about.
So, we just grow, for example, macrophages in our case here.
We slide the tray in, and now these sort of sector one cells are going
to be really happy because they're right next to the opening of the system,
whereas the sector three cells are going to be
completely ischemic.
So it's basically splitting this continuous gradient into discrete bins,
and how many bins you want to study, it's up to you, and how
delicate you want to be. But for our purposes, usually well profused,
ischemic, and intermediate works pretty well.
So the other challenge is that it needs to be much bigger if you want to do omics,
and we didn't know if we would be able to get a linear gradient, and the answer is
yes, we can. So this is HIF-1 alpha.
You see it's across many, many millimeters.
So you can have this system basically as wide as you want, depending on what kind
of biochemistry you need.
So here I'm just showing an example, where,
Logan, a student in the lab, extracted cells from these different regions
and then simply plotted for HIF-1 alpha.
And you can see again, sector one, no HIF-1 alpha, and then you see the
progressive
increment. And Logan is incredibly talented, so he went and tried
with four sectors and five sectors, and you see these really nice
changes. So the system is working well.
So what we did was to take macrophages, right?
Incubate them into the system, and we validated that the
macrophages here would indeed upregulate arginase 1,
and macrophages in this region would not.
So what we were asking is,
what sort of metabolic changes would
stand out specifically in these macrophages?
So
we see a lot of things changing, not surprisingly.
But if we focus here, and this was using untargeted metabolomics,
we found two peaks here.
It's like a hundredfold increase
in a metabolite here. Those two peaks were the same metabolite, which is this
N1 acetylspermidine, which I didn't know existed, and I didn't
want to know existed. But here we were.
That's why we paid the untargeted metabolomics.
So we didn't really know what it was doing, or there was not really
much about it. This is just the same data showing the raw data, right?
So this is like a hundredfold increase.
But actually,
it wasn't perhaps that surprising because arginase 1, it's part of the
urea cycle, but it's also
the entry point for the
synthesis of polyamines because you make ornithine, and
then once you catalyze this step
where you make putrescine from ornithine,
the
pathway is irreversible. So those
atoms are committed now to polyamines.
So the cells, the only
way to get rid of these polyamines is actually by secreting it in the form of these
acetylated polyamines. And we thought that was interesting because,
again, we were thinking, how is this arginase 1 affecting other
cells in the microenvironment? So if this is a secreted
metabolite, could be affecting tumor growth
or other factors, specifically T cell killing.
And
it doesn't affect tumor growth at all.
A very, very marginal effect, depending on the cell line, but not really.
What it does, though, it severely affect T cell killing of tumors.
So I'll just show you. So this is a simple assay with co-culture B16
melanoma cells.
And then we have a transgenic mouse whose T cells recognize an
endogenous peptide of these cells.
So these PMEL cell, PMEL-1 T cells, are incredibly efficient at killing these
tumors. So in 24 hours, they're all dead.
But if we culture them in the presence of this metaboliteThe
macrophage secreted metabolite,
there is still some killing, but it's much
reduced. So here's a quantification of this killing efficiency,
and we've tried a few different antigen models.
And it seems that the inhibition is proportional to the strength of the antigen,
which I think it's quite interesting.
So
if anyone wants to discuss about how it's affecting the T cell killing,
we can discuss that later. We think actually it's producing a
pretty unique effect of allowing empty MHC-1 to go to the
surface, because we don't see any decrease in MHC-1.
What we see is a decrease of peptide bound or antigen bound
MHC-1.
So we can discuss about that later if anyone is interested.
But the thing that was
surprising is that this metabolite, the one that is secreted by
macrophages, is processed by PAOX into
spermidine.
Spermidine had no effect, but the other metabolite, this
3-AP or 3-acetylaminopropanol, another metabolite that didn't exist or
didn't want to exist,
has the full effect.
So basically, we need PAOX or this metabolite to inhibit T cell
killing requires the function of PAOX.
And because we knew that there would be effects in antigen presentation,
we decided to see what happens if we block this enzyme in tumor cells.
And what you find is a complete reversion.
So now these T cells are still exposed to the same metabolite.
The tumors are still exposed to the same metabolite.
But because they don't have the oxidase that catalyzes that
acetylated polyamine, they are now sensitive again,
and T cells can kill them immediately.
So
we did an adoptive transfer experiment, which is
compare the growth of these tumors with wild type for PAOX
versus knockout, and you have a pretty drastic tumor
reduction when you transfer T cells that would be able to recognize this
tumor. So we think it could be a pretty interesting immunosuppressive
mechanism.
So I guess what you're thinking is, do tumors really need this sort of convoluted
acetylated polyamine mechanism? It sounds weird, right? I agree.
So I think it's a real mechanism, but I don't think it's the
only one. And actually,
in our system, the mimic I showed you, the system I showed you at the beginning,
if you co-culture tumor cells with T cells that recognize those tumor
cells, no macrophage, just the tumor cells and the
T cells.
Again, in well-perfused regions, the tumor
cells are wiped out right away. But as you move deeper
into the ischemic region,
the tumor cells remain alive. The T cells are alive.
They're just not killing the tumor.
We know that the T cells are alive because you can literally break the glass
here, and 12 hours later, those T cells are going to be killing the
tumor. So they are
just simply not killing. So
because now we have the system where we can do these omics or
separation, we can take T cells
and tumor cells in
these different regions and sequence them and see what's different between
them. So here what I'm showing you, this would be a conventional
culture. So you have the tumor cells alone, the T cells alone, and in the
co-culture, this is how they look.
If you look now in our system where you have the ischemic gradient,
you can see in the sector one, the well-perfused region,
they look pretty much like a normal co-culture of T cells and tumor cells.
But in the ischemic region, you see completely different populations.
So these are how tumor cells being killed or exposed to T
cells
under ischemia look like, and the same for T cells.
All of this is unpublished, so please do not post.
I love that you're taking photos of me, but just don't.
So what we are doing now, and for the next 20
minutes of my talk,
I'll just
briefly mention what we're trying to do with this data.
So now that we know what's different about these T
cells and about these tumor cells, we are trying to see which
pathways are enriched or modulated.
So we're running
screens to see if we can rescue the killing
into these regions based on their genes or the pathways that we see
altered in these different regions.
So with that, I just wanted to thank my group and
happy to take any questions. And apologies for the closet malfunction
of the PowerPoint.
Meanwhile,
while the audience is deciding on questions, I had a question about how well
do you think the mimic--
how similar or different it is from a conventional hypoxia chamber
in terms of the output? And what is actually the more
realistic output with what you see in vivo in terms of
ischemia?
So
most of the things we've observed, they do not happen only in
hypoxia.
We think that the decrease of nutrients, the
lowering of pH in
ischemia, it's
pretty important. So yeah, it's very different to what we see in hypoxia.
And didn't show the data, but we have
RNASeq data of, for example, macrophages in these different regions and
compared them to just macrophages cultured in hypoxia, and it's
completely
different.So
just email me.
To you?
You just email me.
Okay.
Yeah. And then
we 3D print them in the lab, so that's probably the
easiest. But for the one for imaging, we already
published it so that you can download all the maps For
the biochemical one, it's not published yet,
but we can share it.
Carlos, great talk. I was wondering, in some cancers,
there's loss of urea cycle. A lot of some of the enzymes get downregulated or
suppressed epigenetically, et cetera.
So I wonder if you've looked at whether the status of the urea cycle in the
cancer cells matters in the context of production of-
Yeah
... NASP.
So yeah, that's interesting. So even if we think
or we got to this weird polemine through the arginase one and
macrophages, we are actually now thinking that this mechanism
could be actually achieved by other
ways. In fact, what we see now is
actually
the key thing is acrolein, and we think it's producing protein acroleinization and
producing some different post-translational modification that
change the immune function. So if it's all about acrolein, you
don't really need this mechanism. Just smoke a cigarette, right?
So I think basically this is probably
one of the ways you can get to this, but presumably other cells can do
it without arginase one, arginase two, that is also quite common in
many tumors. So, I guess there is different path to get to
probably similar mechanisms. To me, it's more that
you can start exploring relatively complex
questions with a system that is quite simple.
So as long as you have the right question and the right model, this could give you
additional information to complement other experiments.
So this is not to say that this is the immunosuppressive mechanism
or even the main one. It's just showing you how with
pretty minimalistic system, you still see
a phenomenon that pops up that you would otherwise miss.
Right. Thanks.
Excellent.
Can I get control of the mouse, please?
Do you have the control of the mouse now?
No, I do not.
Okay, great.
All right, so really some very thought-provoking talks.
I really learned a lot. Hope you guys have enjoyed that so far.
So to close out this session by talking a bit about our work on the necrotic niche
and its role in metastatic dissemination, something that was brought up earlier
on in this session. So I think we all appreciate that the main
clinical challenge facing most patients with, let's say, solid tumors, is
metastasis. And really the struggle here is that while most
cancer that's caught at an early stage can be cured with
surgery, radiation,
adjuvant therapy,
for a good number that progresses to a distant recurrence
and that then blossoms into many sites of metastatic disease,
which becomes progressively therapy resistant and then ultimately lethal for the
patient. This is one of the main mysteries, that
cancer and metastatic progression is both highly
inefficient, but on the other side, it is highly robust and
resistant to treatment. And so the essential question that I think many of
us are trying to answer is what are the forces that drive development
of lethal therapy-resistant metastatic cancer?
Now, I think at this stage, we all appreciate that cancer is a multicellular
ecosystem, and we've moved beyond the idea that cancer is just a genetic disease
of individual cells, to understanding they involve interactions between different
types of tumor cells, and also that these are decorated with a variety of immune
and stromal cell types that modify the behaviors.
And the structure of this ecosystem impacts metastatic
potential and therapy resistance.
How we got interested in necrosis originates from our interest and the interest of
others in the role of tumor cell clusters as these mini ecosystems.
Shown on the left, an example is of a circulating tumor cell cluster collected
from a patient treated at Fred Hutchinson, where I am.
This patient had, as you can see, EPCAM positive, CK
positive
tumor cells. And what's important is that
a variety of us in the field have been investigating the properties of
these different CTC clusters, which are coated with different types of
cells, neutrophils, fibroblasts,
sort of thrombotic sort of proteins, T-cells,
and this has been nicely summarized by a nice sort of piece by Mitch Leslie in
"Science," just came out, I think, last week.
Now, what's important is that these mini ecosystems have outsized
metastatic potential. And a number of studies by us, Nick
Seddo, Ben Stanger, our group, and a number of other groups
since then, have shown that you can track, in particularly mouse models, and
look at the sort of clonality of cells in the primary tumor with
different sort of red and green fluorescent proteins and other colors.
And if you look at the mets, what you discover is that you can find mets with this
polyclonal sort of
composition. And this is really remarkable because it's known, I
think in most studies, I wouldn't say all studies, but most studies would suggest
that CTC clusters are pretty rare in the liquid biopsy fraction, and yet
these, in a variety of mouse models, have shown to be able to form between
50% and 90% of metastases. And in particular, the clustering of tumor cells
together increases metastatic potential 50 to 500 fold.
So this is a large magnitude effect.
In addition, this is a mini ecosystem in which you can start to
decode what are the essential factors.The other aspect that I have
been, and my colleagues are particularly interested in, is that the idea
that cancer cells might travel together in the metastatic process is well
appreciated now. Collective migration is a common mode in both development and
cancer, and it really involves, both in development and in cancer
models, plasticity states, something we talked about, I heard about today at the
plenary session, involving different cell populations,
basal and luminal, that interact to drive collective
invasion. And shown here is a nice sort of mammary organoid invasion
model taken by one of my students, Justin Huey, who is actually going to be
giving a poster on Tuesday. If you want, come by his
poster, check it out if you'd like to hear more about our work trying to understand
the role of plasticity and ways to target it in collective migration.
Now, what's important is that these multicellular interactions give rise to
emergent properties.
Individual cells have certain capabilities, but when they are together with their
neighbors, they acquire different abilities such as multitasking,
redundancy, the ability to form self-generated gradients, and the ability to be
stable despite fluctuating cues.
And these require a variety of homotypic and heterotypic adhesion
systems, cell-cell interactions that allow for very
complicated multicellular behavior.
For example, one area that we
showed a while back was that tumor cell clusters, when you drill down into their
sort of intracellular structure by electron microscopy, contain these intracellular
channels. These intracellular channels, in fact, harbor an accumulation of growth
factors, in this case, epigen, a EGF family growth factor.
And these concentrate in these spaces and very absolutely required
for metastasis. And so what's really remarkable here is
that clusters then, not only are immuno ecosystems, but also
produce factors that allow them to carry their own local
microenvironments that manifest as useful for metastatic colonization.
Altogether, in the field, I think we've become very interested in this notion of a
collective model of metastasis, where clusters, as we know and the pathologists
appreciate, can invade blood and lymphatic vessels.
And over a course of months to years, these clusters are found across
the stages of metastatic progression, and in large numbers can allow for
polyclonal seeding, genetic heterogeneity,
overcome a variety of bottlenecks in the metastatic process, and even
can cause direct injury to vital organs such as the brain,
the lung, liver,
perhaps even to the heart.
And these emergent properties involve a variety of increasing resistance
to immunologic and seer stress, detachment, metastatic
potential, and involves the transport
a variety of cell and sort of ecosystem components.
Now, in my lab, we became interested in necrosis by asking the question, what are
the microenvironmental forces that drive collective tumor dissemination?
This is work really led by a very talented graduate student in my lab, Ami
Yamamoto, who's now since in industry.
And this really begins with sort of a clinical study that we performed really
during the COVID era, trying to understand what are the factors
associated with sort of circulating tumor cell dissemination.
And what we found in our patients at the Fred Hutch is that you could find these
single CCCs and CTC clusters. And as
has been seen by a number of other studies, the presence of CTCs and CTC
clusters is a very sort of negative prognostic
feature. And particularly for CTC clusters, within even a few months,
many of the patients
had to go into hospice or no longer had any therapy that would benefit
them.
But when we looked more closely, also we found that there were some really unusual
CTC dynamics. And in particular, we could see that CTCs rised
acutely.
In this case, you see CA 15-3 is a blood marker, LDH.
CTCs rise, in this case, up to 1,000 from a very low number.
CTC clusters rise. And in this patient,
basically very soon after, they were admitted for liver injury and tumor
lysis. And when we look at the CT scan, when you have a very high, from low to high
CTC transition, you see emergence of this necrosis on the
actual scan. This is a sort of a
multi capturing CT scan that allows us to look at the
microenvironment.
When we looked at sort of the proteomics of the patients who had these
acute rises in CTCs, interestingly, we saw acute
rise in proteins associated with lactic acid metabolism and also proteins
associated with cell death. And this was one of the first clues that, in fact,
CTCs are somehow coupled to
death-associated proteins.
And so we wanted to study this more closely in animal model.
And as you know, many in the audience who study mouse models of cancer,
mice individually do not have a lot of blood volume between 0.5 to 1 mil.
Humans, we can draw 10 mils in a draw, which is actually only a small
fraction of the five liters in the entire system.
We became interested in using rats because they are much more
robust as a system to obtain 5 to 10 mils of blood.
And what we found using the common 4T1 model, as Jose
also used earlier, is that if you implant the same number of cells into NSG mice or
SRG immunocompromised rats,
we could very cleanly, with microscopy, identify individual CTCs and
CTC clusters. And we could obtain, in an individual animal, 10 times more
CTCs than in a comparable mouse.
And why this is important, because then we can start to ask the question, on an
individual animal basis, what are the dynamics?
What are the causes and factors that give rise to CTC induction?
So when we looked at the
CTC dynamics, what we arrived at was something unusual.
We expected in this sort of animal experiment, days
post-transplantation, to have a continuous rise.
But what we saw actually was this acute jump between day 22 and 27.
This kind of hockey stick phenomena suggests that CTC is bursting.
And we want to understand more closely what is happening in this sort of CT
transition phase.
Working with our colleague, Mike Hafner, a very talented pathologist, he said,
"Kevin, we look at the edges of these tumors.
They look identical from day 13 to day 27.
There's nothing different about the tumor edge.
But what's clearly different is that there's a lot more necrosis.
There's a lot more cell death inside these tumors.
And really, this necrotic area very strongly increases between day 22 and
27."And here's an example of a very classic,
you can use a TTZ assay, a trypan blue chloride assay.
Red is the viable tissue. Yellow marks the dead tissue.
And this is a sort of myocardial infarction heart attack.
You can see very similar sort of
kinetics here. Day 20, you see there's mostly viable.
By day 24, you see these large confluent zones.
I do think that, as Jose brought up, there is microscopic, and we'll talk
about it later, small areas necrosis, but these do progressively
become confluent and dominant. And when you look at tumors later on, although
the tumors are growing, a lot of it is dead.
And what's really interesting here is on a per animal basis, we found that the
number of lung metastases shown you in the x-axis was highly correlated with the
amount of necrosis, not with total tumor size.
And so what this says is that there's a component of chance here.
Some tumors develop necrosis. The ones that develop necrosis
are the ones that develop metastatic cancer.
One other thing we noticed was that in close association with
necrosis was the presence of these dilated blood vessels.
Blood vessels that appear to be penetrating into the necrotic zone from the sort of
perinecrotic region.
Quite dilated. And in particular, when we look more closely at these
dilated vessels, we could find evidence of tumor cell clusters and tumor cells in
these intravascular zones. This is really remarkable because
necrosis is happening a lot of times deep within the tumor.
These we're talking about between many millimeters to even centimeters in these
rat tumors. This is really pretty far from the tumor edge, and yet we see
there's a mechanism by which these cells get in there.
So what these data thus far tell us that necrotic transition is closely associated
with CTC and CT cluster dissemination in patients and animal models.
I want to focus now on two questions.
How can a dead necrotic core cause dissemination?
And are tumor cells passive bystanders in this process?
We performed RNA expression analysis.
This is basically using, like in this case, SRG rats, 421 is a mouse
line. We're able to do some RNA seq deconvolution.
It's nothing fancy. As you might expect,
there's both tumor and host-derived transcriptional changes.
But this is really interesting because it turns out that the tumor itself in these
core regions produce their own distinct sets of proteins.
This was a question brought up by someone in the audience.
In this case, we found that the top protein being expressed was this protein
called angiopoietin-like 7. It's a member of this angiopoietin-like family.
Other members are FDA-approved drug targets in
cardiovascular indications. And what we see here is a strong
induction in the core but not in the rim, and it's a tumor-derived, not a
host-derived factor. This is a common issue.
You might go after a drug target,
but if it's both tumor and host-derived, it's going to be a little bit messy to
figure out what's going on. Here's clearly this is a tumor-derived
protein.
And we can see very nicely by, in this case, RNA fish, shown here in green,
that the regions are necrotic, and then the red is the angiopoietin-like 7
RNA fish spots, and you can see that it's enriched in the core.
Now, one of the things that we found was this chicken or the egg.
Well, it turns out when we knock down angiopoietin-like 7 in the
tumor cells, we drastically reduce necrosis.
So necrosis is actually a preventable process.
Knockdown also reduces dilated vessel abundance.
And also further, suppression of angiopoietin-7 basically takes CTC
dissemination down close to zero in the
strongest knockdowns in both single CTCs and CTC clusters.
So in fact, the tumor cells are producing a factor which is regulating
CTC and CTC cluster dissemination.
These also lead to downstream reductions in lung metastasis.
So how can a dead necrotic zone cause dissemination?
Well, there are viable perinecrotic tumor cells engaging the tumor
necrotic zone. And are tumor cells passive bystanders
in this process? Well, our data would suggest the tumor cells actively
produce proteins which promote necrotic core transition.
So with the time remaining, I wanted to focus on some of our
unpublished work to understand what are the cellular and molecular
architecture of tumor necrosis in human cancer patients.
As I talked about in the beginning of this session, this is
oftentimes an area of the tumor which we kind of actively
ignore because our expectation is that the cells are dead.
But as the other presenters have really nicely shown, there's a lot of interesting
biology there.
And so working closely with our colleague, Christopher Lee,
and his statistical analyst, and also Rebecca Alvarez in
UW Breast Pathology, we employed Christopher's
Bravo study, which is basically over 4,000 breast cancer patients recruited
in the Washington State area, was oversampling for different breast
cancer subtypes.
There's over 1,500 triple negative cases.
And they're really able then to use these kind of case matching to get really good
matched cases that differ really only between those that recur and do not
recur.
Focusing on 140 of these cases over 800 slides, we then,
Rebecca and her colleagues, have reviewed these slides for lymphovascular
invasion, necrosis, dilated vessels, and their spatial location.
And so our goal was to understand the association between each of these histologic
features with clinical pathologic features and clinical outcome.
Now, what did we find?
We were really surprised. So when Rebecca looked at these
slides, she came back and said to me, "Hey, Kevin, it's a little more complicated
than you might have imagined. It's not just necrosis or no necrosis.
In fact, there are different histologies that coexist in the same breast
tumor." This is an example of a central necrosis
region in a triple negative tumor.
But what we can see very clearly is there are regions with high amounts of
coagulative necrosis and also areas with what we call reparative changes,
things that are commonly associated with what we call wound repair.
Now, what's interesting is these coagulative necrosis reparative changes are
highly associated with each other.
So the more coagulative necrosis you have, the more reparative changes, but
not totally just sort of on a one-to-one
basis.One of the interesting thing is coagul necrosis was inversely
associated with lymphovascular invasion which is occurring outside the tumor.
So in fact, these might be perhaps linked in some way, which we don't fully
understand yet and these reparative changes often directly
were adjacent to a coagulum necrosis, but not
always. But what's really interesting is that it turns out
from a prognostic implications standpoint, they seem to differ.
Coagulum necrosis was not particularly prognostic whereas
reparative changes were highly prognostic.
5% or more of the tumor having reparative changes
basically predicted much worse prognosis,
and this was highly prognostic for breast cancer recurrence, all-cause
mortality, and breast cancer specific mortality, including when you
adjust for a variety of sort of key factors associated with, including tumor
stage, age, and competing non-breast cancer death.
Furthermore, and particularly interesting for us, thinking about how these might be
deployed in the future in a clinical setting, we found the reparative changes
in lymphovascular invasion were independently prognostic and identify a
high-risk triple negative subgroup that with both LVI and high
reparative, had very early recurrences in the triple negative
population, and much worse mortality.
And this was highly significant,
with a hazard ratio up to five.
So this is really exciting to us because it tells us that tumor necrosis
is not one state, but multiple states, and what we see, in fact, is a
history of a dynamic process.
You look at... This is Apollo Moon mission image, maybe timely
in the news, and the point is that you can see the craters
here reflect the different ages, the history of many events.
And when we look more closely with our pathologist, we see evidence
also of different components of neutrophils and macrophages monocytes,
which I'll talk more about in particular, our animal model.
So then the final part of the talk, I want to talk a bit about some of our work
led by Alex Reir, is a talented graduate student in my lab, trying to understand
how this angiopoietin-like 7 is regulating tumor necrosis dynamics.
So first we developed a complete angiopoietin-like 7
knockout, and in both immunocompetent and immunocompromised settings,
here shown in Balb C, we see a drastic reduction in necrosis.
We see a reduction in also tumor volume in this case, and also metastasis and
metastatic area. So using this complete knockout, we
then perform a multiplex, multiscale profiling
of tumor necrosis to understand tumor cell dynamics.
And what's interesting here is here's an example of four T one parental tumor.
Here's an area of sort of necrosis. All well and good.
We look at these regions, we can find evidence of endothelial cells, dilated blood
vessels I described earlier. We see plenty of neutrophils, and we also see
lots of citrullinated histone H3, as Jose nicely
brought up, which represent these nets and dying neutrophils.
But what I want to highlight also is that you can step back.
If you step back, what's clear is there is mesoscale heterogeneity in the
system. The CD31, the citrulline
H3, these are occurring in different regions, and they don't necessarily occur in
the same spots as the highest areas of neutrophils.
And if you zoom in on these areas of high neutrophils, as
Dr. Andreva nicely brought up, we see evidence of these
high zones of neutrophils with CD31 pods regions.
They have mild peroxidase,
and these areas identify these sort of early necrotic regions.
But what's also interesting here from a pathology standpoint is that when we
then we can find other sort of regions in this constellation of sort of within the
tumor that don't have any obvious H&E correlate.
So it suggests that we can go back and forth between understanding the
biology from a pathologist perspective to understanding this multiplex
IHC and learn something about how necrosis dynamics is occurring.
We also see evidence that in these dilated vessels,
there are these intravascular nets.
I think one of the areas that we are very interested in now moving forward is how
these perhaps neutrophils and nets might be interacting to allow for these CTC
clusters to disseminate.
But in addition, as many in the audience would appreciate, we can also see
macrophages as well, a
major component of these four T one tumors.
We see evidence that there's primarily CD163 negative
macrophages in these early necrotic regions,
but that in these sort of late necrotic regions, we see many of these CD163
positive, sort of consistent with these sort of reparative programs that we talked
about earlier in the discussion.
Now, how does angiopoietin-7 knockout affect this?
Well, one is it appears to change the sort of the
clustering and zonal enrichment of neutrophils and their
downstream sort of markers.
It
didn't reach the significance. We clearly see their speckling is something
that is clearly reduced. But what's also interesting is that even in the setting
complete knockout, our pathologist was saying, "Well, this is really interesting."
You can find these areas of what we call sort of adipocytes that appear to be
attacked by neutrophils, which we don't fully understand yet.
But our pathologist was like, "This reminds me of cystic neutrophilic
granulomatous mastitis." So there's a connection between adipocytes and
neutrophil attack, which something that should be investigated
further. In addition, we see a marked change in terms of
the clustering of macrophages and in macrophage polarization.
If you knock out angiopoietin-like 7, you see a shift towards a more
inflammatory and less sort of reparative sort of program.
And what's most remarkable for us is that we saw a significant reduction in the
abundance of total TGF-beta in angiopoietin-7 knockout, and this is highly
significant. We also saw reductions in PSMAD
signaling as well, and so this puts this into
perspective that perhaps
TGF-beta, the gradient, is somehow being
affected by angiopoietin-like 7 and affecting the macrophage,
most likely production of it. So our current working model, this is a work in
progress here, is that-There are multiple phases of necrosis.
These involve dying neutrophils, NET formation, and dilated vessels.
But there is a component in this system that involves TGF beta
1 and that is clearly apparently regulated by angiopoietin 7.
And so this idea is that there are components of the tumor cell sort
of ecosystem that are produced by tumor cells themselves that help to
amplify the system that promotes metastasis.
I then want to close with the idea that do cancer therapies make necrosis worse?
Very possibly.
Others have shown us this as well, that if you treat tumors with paclitaxel, other
chemotherapies, you can increase metastatic dissemination.
What we find is if we reduce angiopoietin 7, we can suppress this.
And so one of the areas is can we suppress angiopoietin 7 to make it more
effective? So key takeaways. Thank you for your time.
Tumor cell clusters are mini ecosystems.
The necrotic extrusion is closely associated with CTC and CTC cluster
dissemination. Perinecrotic tumor cells are viable and produce angiopoietin
7 and necrosis-promoting protein.
And importantly, in clinical settings, there are different phases of necrosis
progression, and these have independent prognostic impact, particularly reparative
changes. In a complete A7 knockout model, tumor-produced
angiopoietin 7 supports TGF beta abundance and shifts in neutrophil and
macrophage states.
Key directions moving forward. Can A7 suppress and therapeutically normalize
necrosis? And
it's not classical invasion metastatic cascade.
How do CTC clusters intravasate from necrotic zone?
So
there's a group, a large group, Alex, Nicole, Emma, Amy, and Yamas, who
helped contribute to this work, as well as my collaborators at Hutch and elsewhere.
Thank you very much for your time and happy taking questions.
Hi.
Great talk. I was just wondering that have you
checked whether depletion of these macrophages impact the
necrosis and their dissemination and metastasis?
We haven't done that experiment. I think there's different genetic
approaches that would be helpful to really be definitive about that, in
particularly in a fully immunocompetent setting.
But yeah, I think this is one of the things, there's a chicken, egg component.
Both the neutrophils, the macrophages, the fibroblasts, these are all interacting
in the system. And the question is, I think it's leading us to ask, which is
the sort of main source of this TGF beta, and how is that being regulated
by our protein? But that's a very good question, yes.
It's really a great talk. Did you try to deplete macrophage, neutrophil,
and see the consequence of the necrosis or that metastasis?
I think that my colleagues have also depleted
neutrophils, and they see evidence that it can reduce necrosis.
I think
this is one of the things where I think that there are going to be systemic effects
of depleting the immune system entirely.
One of the things we're really excited about is perhaps
our work might suggest that necrosis is certainly, and
my colleagues here, that it's sort of immunosuppressive in many
ways. And so at what arm of targeting
necrosis can you sort of reinvigorate the immune system to kill
cancer cells is, I think, a very important area. But I agree with you.
Yes, that's it.
But the reason is like which
provoke my thought, like there is a paper in Julio's lab.
Oh, yeah. Julio. Yeah.
Well,
you show the TGF beta, just ignore me that they showed like those alveolar
macrophage, secret TGF beta, it provoked like TGF beta receptor.
Yes.
Where does CTC fit in that hypothesis?
Yeah, that's a good question. Obviously, Julio's work, a lot of it is in the HER2
model, but
it would be a good suggestion to sort of see how those connect
with the work we're doing there. Yeah.
Great talk. I was wondering if there is any connection
perhaps with the necrosis and some specific
tumor behavior, like is there any association with ECM
deposition? And I'm asking this because TGF beta has been
associated with promoting more an ECM-rich
microenvironment.
Yeah, I'm also work actually on the metastasis, and I found that there is high
association with TGF beta, so I'm interested.
Oh, yes. It's very interesting. I think one of the things, we already know that, I
think there are different matrix molecules that are enriched in the tumor core
and the rim, and in these necrotic zones in particular.
So I think that the reparative regions, and in particular,
during wound repair, there is a provisional matrix.
But that matrix is different from the sort of desmoplastic matrix that you might
see in sort of mature or at the edge of the tumor.
So I think that's a great question.
How TGF beta is influencing matrix deposition is something that I think is a
very promising area in necrotic regions. Yeah.
Thank you.
All right.
You guys want to do any-- Come to the tier to have any
additional questions about the group or we're pretty much good?
Okay. Well, just come up, and then if there are any questions, that's great.
Okay. That's fine.
So I'll just open up. Jose, first question, so you know it's well known in
breast cancer that a lot of chemotherapies are sort of
cardiotoxic and can cause
cardiomyopathies. Do you think there could be a role for neutrophils there?
Have you begun looking in that?
So we're looking at that a little bit.
But the main point that we're trying to make is that there's likely
effects beyond the therapies.
Mm-hmm.
So there's a lot of effort on the therapies, and rightly so, because they are
cardiotoxic. But what we're particularly interested is in what the
neutrophils could be doing beyond the therapy effect.
Great section. I can start the questions.
For the last presentation,
when you block necrosis to happen, do you see changes in the
blood
numbers of neutrophils? What I'm trying to say is, many
tumors, they shed signals to the bone marrow to release more inflammatory
cells in the blood that also go to the tumor.
Do you
think when you block necrosis, that also
affects that effect?
That's a great question. I think that the question is--
This is an area of obviously a lot of interest in terms of systemic
reprogramming of the bone marrow.
And,
for instance, angiopoietin 7 has been identified potentially as a stem
cell marker. It stimulates hematopoietic stem cells as well.
So it is possible that there is a sort of systemic effect of this
protein.
I suppose that could be addressed more cleanly with different types of
co-culture type experiments or mixing experiments to see whether it's a local or a
systemic effect. That's a great suggestion.
Thank you. And I have one question for the second presenter.
So in your model of hypoxia, I saw you show the data until
like 72 hours. So what happened with the cells
after that time? Do they
adopt and the macrophage
start to shed more growth factors or anything, or
they just die?
Well, it depends on the cell type.
So I guess one thing I would say is that it's much more than
hypoxia. And I think that was Kevin's discussion.
So I call it ischemia because I think
many things are changing at the same time.
I know macrophages can live there for a week or yeah.
And they change their expression patterns, they change their behavior, they
become more phagocytic.
And then
with highly proliferative cells,
very far from the
opening, you start seeing cell death about
after 48 hours. And that's mostly lactic acid
accumulation. So it's not hypoxia related.
Well, independently hypoxia triggers more lactic acid production,
but what makes it lethal is the drop in the pH.
So if you, for example, add more bicarbonate, you reduce the cell death.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great talk. So I just want a simple question.
For the macrophage, the second talk.
The macrophage when the hypoxia induced the arginase
increase.
Can we say just like the macrophage
shifted to the M2 type?
So we know the tumor associated to the macrophage, they had two type,
the M1 type and M2 type. The M2 type is the
arginase increase. So is it possible we can shift
the M2 type to the M1 type that can
anti-tumor cancer?
Yeah. So I sometimes jokingly say that M1, M2
macrophages only exist in PubMed.
But
the answer is no. So you see arginase 1, but you also see
iNOS.
So if you look at the markers,
they downregulate or upregulate
markers that would be typically associated with either group.
So they are proangiogenic, they are anti-inflammatory, but
other than arginase 1, I think there is not real full resemblance to the
M2.
And if you look in view, most of the macrophages that
are sort of especially at the single cell level that are identified, they don't
really match M1 or M2 either.
Thank you.
Great. I think this has been a very stimulating discussion, and
thank you to the other speakers. Thank you to the audience for
being with us, and have a good rest of your day.
Thank you